hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and if you're familiar with my
book the big picture or any of the
various talks I've given on that book
you'll know that one of my favorite
factoids is that the average human
lifespan is 3 billion heartbeats that's
not a very profound fact if you just
take the fact that the average human
being lives for about 75 years and your
dimensional analysis to convert from
years to heartbeats the number works out
to be about 3 billion for a typical
human being stretching from birth to
death but it's an interesting fact
because it brings home in a slightly
more vivid way how short our life is 3
billion is a big number but it's not
unimaginably big and unlike years
heartbeats are going by all the time
you've squandered several of your
heartbeats already listening to me talk
right here and I learned this fact about
the three billion heartbeats from
today's guest dr. Jeffery West
who's a distinguished professor at the
Santa Fe Institute and it's in the
context of a much more profound fact
about biological organisms here on earth
if you take any particular kind of
organism let's say mammals because human
beings are mammals they come in all
shapes and sizes there's tiny little
mice there's big old blue whales or
elephants but there are relationships
between the size of an animal in mass
for example the number of kilograms the
thing has and other biological facts
such as how long it lives bigger animals
whales and elephants live for much
longer than tinier things like mice or
squirrels meanwhile there's another
relationship between your size and your
heart rate big animals like whales and
elephants have very slow heartbeats tiny
animals have very rapid heartbeats and
you can see where this is going these
two facts exactly cancel out the average
number of heartbeats for mammals is
approximately the same for tiny little
mice or big old blue whales or elephants
it's not an exact relationship in fact
the number for a typical mammal works
out not to be three billion but one and
a half billion which maybe you could
argue is
Lee what we had we human beings back in
the state of nature before we had
pasteurized milk and Obamacare and
things like that but the point is that
something is going on that goes beyond
mere biology there's some reason why
there's a relationship between how fast
your heart beats how massive you are and
how long you live that's what got
today's guest Geoffrey West interested
in biology networks and complex systems
he started his academic life as a
particle physicist but he read about
these scaling relations and he realized
from his physics point of view no one
understood them no one knew why things
were like that so he and his
collaborators developed a theory that
explains why you get this relationship
as an animal gets bigger it lives longer
but its heart slows down the pace of
life is slower for larger animals these
days he's extending that analysis not
just to individual animals but to cities
or cultures or other kinds of networks
that fill our daily lives today this
kind of analysis is absolutely crucial
for sustainability for thinking about
how we live in the world for choosing
how to manage our life here on earth
Jeffery West is the former president of
the Santa Fe Institute and he's the
author of a wonderful recent book called
scale the universal laws of growth
innovation sustainability and the pace
of life in organisms cities economies
and companies it's not the most elegant
title I'll give you that was an
extremely important and hopefully
influential book that helps us
understand the world we live in
so let's go
[Music]
Jeffrey west welcome to the podcast
hey nice to be here Sean thank you for
inviting me so I have to ask when you're
on an airplane going to a conference
traveling around the world and you find
yourself sitting next to an inquisitive
type and they say so what do you do for
a living what is your answer to that
kind of question oh goodness me that's a
tough one and I and it always stops me
in my tracks but a because I'm slightly
misanthropic but what do I say I I think
I always lead off pretty much by saying
I'm a physicist and then I quickly say
I'm a physicist but I I work now a lot
in questions challenges that are
considered outside of usual physics and
I've done quite a lot of work in you
know what I would consider fundamental
questions in biology and now about
cities companies and and I'm
particularly interested in the whole
question of global sustainability right
so I sort of do it in that I mean maybe
not quite as you know linearly as that
but effectively but now in your youth
you were more or less mainstream
absolutely so what kinds of things did
you work on then and what happened so
yes so most of my career meaning the
first 30 odd years I did definitely what
you would call mainstream particle
physics even entering it when I would
say that the kinds of things you work on
and you've made your name on or
considered way out you know they weren't
questions a real physicist should be
answered asking a bestmile ejido yeah
yeah it was like come on you know and I
think one of the by the way just
tangentially one of the great things
that has happened in physics is that we
do ask those questions and we address
them seriously and it's now developed
into its own thing
it's had profound influence but back
then I was too mainstream physicists
working on
well I entered it very fortunately had a
really opportune moment because these
famous experiments which got the Nobel
Prize at Stanford on which eventually
were interpreted as discovering quarks
were taking place they the results were
just coming out and I had been sort of
the early seventies the well they were
the late 60s actually in late 60s I got
my PhD in 66 and those the accelerator
at Stanford was just being completed and
the first experiments were being
performed and the the results that
changed everything which were results on
an experiment that that's right at the
time was thought of as mundane and
uninteresting appeared and they were
quite surprising and as I say eventually
they were interpreted as the evidence
for quarks and that was a very exciting
period as one tried to interpret those
experiments try to formulate models and
then theories and ultimately the
evolution towards something called
quantum chromodynamics the theory of a
sort of QCD the theory of the strong
interactions and that was very exciting
and did you feel that this is what life
was going to be like every few years you
would discover a new layer of structure
of matter new absolutely nor in fact I
would say during that period from
probably 68 70 onwards through the 70s
and into the early 80s we were kind of
spoiled because every year there was a
new fantastic discovery that you know
either or or confirmation of something
and it was just a marvelous period and
it culminated in
the development of the so called
standard model where we see some court
of grand unification or at least we we
saw that you could contemplate grand
unification of the electromagnetism with
strong forces and so on and that was
just immensely exciting and then that
led to this naivete that it would only
be a few more years where we can get
gravity into the picture and so as I say
but it was a picked a period of immense
excitement and but a period of being
spoiled as one does you know I mean it
reminds me a bit it actually is sort of
interesting when I look back on it
because it also had some of the flavor
of the sixties and seventies in the in
society you know they the the emergence
from the 50s and early 60s and kind of
the image of suburban America with you
know two point four children and in that
image of everybody we all had to
suddenly the psychedelic revolution the
Vietnam War and what the demonstrations
and anti-war movement brought the civil
rights movement so then we hit the
Reagan era and then we hit exactly and
and so it is that in physics we hit not
because of a Robert Reagan or because
there was a vote but because it turns
out that nature was not quite as
forthcoming as we thought or we weren't
smart enough despite you know I said
what I do think was anine you know even
though I've been quite critical of it I
think an extraordinary development and
that is of string theory I mean it was a
marvelous leap but you did mention
discoveries and or confirmations and
there was a shift so after the mid to
late 70s there weren't a lot of more
surprises coming our way we were
confirming things that we had models
that explained and indeed it's sort of
the dirty little secret of particle
physics there haven't been any know
exactly exactly there's been nothing
that
sort of you know in fact the the big
things as you know better than I you
know of gravitational waves of the Higgs
particle and so on are confirmations of
things that in one case were predicted
you know I know what about seventy years
ago or whatever or longer actually and
in the other thirty forty years ago or
whatever it has been but a long time but
I mean very exciting that we have
confirmed those but also especially in
the case of the Higgs it's you know in
it really in some ways it's like the end
of something that's rather than I mean
gravitational waves I think you could
see it is the end of something in a
certain way we don't but it's also the
beginning of sodomy it certainly and it
is exactly and that's the thing it's now
even so that we can use it as a tool
again and so whereas the Higgs is sort
of putting a full-stop a period at the
end of something it's now done and the
big questions that have been there since
the mid to late seventies remain a how
does gravity fit and but even within
grand unified were left with all these
parameters and you know where do they
come we're unified in a certain sense
but in the sense that a physicist would
like ultimately we're still a long way
away no one thinks it's the right final
theory of everything what we have right
now but it's compatible with all the
data this resume ibly played a role in
your choice to become a less mainstream
physicists yes well it did in the
following sense that you know it was it
was frustrating
as time went on but also you know we
suddenly developed this idea of putting
all our eggs into the superconducting
supercollider basket and with the idea
that with this longer reach of energy it
would reveal something exciting you it
would in fact confirm the Higgs of
course but and this was to be sort of
the United States's version of the Large
Hadron Collider but bigger and better
and maybe even sooner and it'll come to
be absolutely and in fact I mean one of
the great ironies again may be used by a
dirty little secret this is also a sort
of dirty little secret I think is that
in the days in which people were
promoting the SSC you know to get the
money for it and just to drum up the
general interest of course the CERN the
Europeans have responded by saying we're
gonna make this Large Hadron Collider
which would be you know almost an order
of magnitude less in energy and the
dirty little secret was that the US
physics community continually badmouth
the LHC I mean it was like oh it's
useless there's no reason to believe
whatsoever they can discover anything
the reach just isn't far enough you've
certainly got to go to you know whatever
was twelve fifteen or even though
ultimately twenty TeV and the the dirty
little secret is in the context of now
that the LHC is the only game in town
and we are involved in it and it
discovered the Higgs all we can do is
talk how fantastic it is and what a
great idea you know and you know it's
it's so physicists are also prone to you
know emotions and politics and all the
rest human beings their human being so I
don't I'm not you know not blaming
anyone but it is it's but we sometimes
suddenly in those days I would say I
think the the the physics the
high-energy physics community was of
course very arrogant because it felt it
was doing the most fundamental and
therefore the most important
science on the planet but also that we
were immune from the the human foibles
such as this and and I think both of
those things have been damaged and
destroyed rightfully I think I think we
were overly arrogant overly
self-involved self-centered the it ended
with you know the calling string theory
the theory of everything which already
connotes a certain attitudes towards
everything else right so you know and I
think that's been in a certain sense
that's been healthy for the field
actually to be honest that that didn't
know that meaning the that this
extraordinary intellectual narcissism
coupled with arrogance which I think
might have served us well for quite a
long while in the you know not saying
that it was necessary but not
questioning yourself does motivate you
yes it does and especially when you
think you're doing the you know the most
exciting fundamental physics that has
universal applicability and is you know
the meaning of life kind of a yeah
that's right and that's very exciting
and that was you know mostly unsaid part
of the culture but when the
superconducting supercollider was
cancelled by Congress in the 1990s
so that affected Europe that's
unexpected as it did yes so I mean it
affected me of these reasons but it also
because I was at Los Alamos at the time
and we had some significant involvement
in in building one of the detectors with
in fact led by Perry bearish like
Caltech your Caltech colleague you of
course of the Nobel Prize for the LIGO
experiment but we were heavily involved
in that and I was a theorist I wasn't
directly heavily involved but that was
part of our program but also a
girlfriend a slight tangent here there
was another phenomenon so I was in my
50s at the time
and I come from a line of short live
males you know my father died in at 61
my grandfather at 57 and so on back I
mean we're all none of us the male line
doesn't live very long it turns out and
for different reasons by the way which
is interesting of itself but so the
reason I say that is because I grew up
with the idea that it was exceedingly
unlikely or rather you expect to die at
about age 16 laughs and here I was you
know I don't know what it was 53 54
maybe and I realized my god we've had
the death of the SS see I'm 54 55
whatever it was at the time and my god I
probably only have five years stretch in
ten years and Wow that's you know what I
should start thinking about what I'm
gonna do when I grow up kind of thing
and you know now the SSC is gone this is
has a big psychological effect but
another thing was happening the death of
the SSC was driven by to some extent by
a big anti science movement in the u.s.
which comes up every once in a while but
in particular it was an auntie physics
one and even more particular it was an
auntie high-energy physics one so that
it was a very peculiar situation that
even our colleagues in other parts of
physics were not supportive right and in
fact they had this mistaken idea that if
they killed the SSC they would all be
rich kind of image which turned out to
be completely untrue to be fair the SSC
would have been very expensive of course
and had all that money gone to the rest
of physics they would have been rich
good what happens never would happen I
was a humongous amount of money on the
scale of a science experiment no
question and
you know there were there were obviously
questions about its viability what it
would actually do and so on you know all
kinds of good good questions but
nevertheless okay there was this anti
particular anti high-energy physics but
one of the things I used to hear both
Los Alamos which after all is a National
Lab with huge numbers of activities
going from the weapons program although
through all the way through to the
multiple areas of the particularly the
physical sciences but I also heard it in
the halls of the Department of Energy in
which were the funding agency for the
SSC was this famous statement physics
was the science of the 19th and 20th
centuries biology is the science of the
21st century and the corollary which was
usually not said but I did hear it
saying I said was therefore no need to
do any more fundamental physics we know
all the physics we need to know that was
said very explicitly very explain that
was you know that really threw me
and so I reacted emotionally to the idea
that well first of all on on on
reflection it was obvious biology was
going to be a major science in the 21st
century no one could doubt that was
clear it was poised for that and if your
question had been do we know all the
fundamental particle physics we need to
do biology and chemistry then the answer
is yes yeah other kinds of physics
absolutely
so your grand unification will have no
impact no impact so this is one of the
we could we should discuss that because
I think that's it remains an issue you
know why are we doing things that have
in any way that we can immediately
conceive anyway any foreseeable
influence on betterment of human life on
the planet making America great again or
whatever in fact work I'd like very much
like to come back to that but our long
more personal lines
I was I reacted a to the idea that
that's nonsense
you know that's really crazy that you
got to support all of physics and you've
got to have people thinking about
fundamental questions if we are to
address fundamental questions in biology
you know that's sort of part of the
culture and more specifically I reacted
by saying that you know if biology were
real science it would be you know you'd
have equations and principles and you
better mathematize things I mean all
very well you know we all know the
principle of evil
natural selection Darwin's contribution
was fantastic but you know except in a
limited way it doesn't predict the kinds
of things we in physics would think you
would need to predict if it were a
complete theory you would want a curve
that you could fit data to and see how
beautiful your predictions exactly and
inside I used to say very you know very
sarcastically you know if you had a real
theory then you could predict that they
should be human beings I mean take you
to an extreme but so I would push back
with that at various meetings you know
and discussions and then I started to
think you know my god maybe I should
take that seriously you know that
biology really you know does need what I
would say is biology needs not just the
techniques that physics uses the
mathematical techniques but equally and
possibly even more important it needs to
integrate in a way of thinking a certain
culture which I and and I must tell you
this was out of like this arrogance of
the high energy physicist and also out
of ignorance of biology so it was really
emotional you know I mean a perfect
storm a perfect storm for disaster but
then I started thinking about it and I
combined these two things the fact that
maybe I was going to die soon the SSC is
dead
they're telling us that physics should
be dead the kind of physics I have
excited about and we should all be doing
biology and I thought about that and I
thought you know I wonder if if biology
were a science like physics there ought
to be in a biology book a calculation of
why it is that my life span even though
I'm only gonna live to 60 or 65 I
thought of that time even conceivably I
wouldn't live to a hundred hundred where
does the hundred years come from right
you know so I started reading biology
books so you're worried not about why 60
but why not a second or a millennium yes
so where does this scale where does the
overall scale that's the physicists way
of thinking not just the mechanism what
is the mechanism that's leading through
aging to mortality but where what sets
the scale of aging of life's man of the
hundred years so I started reading and I
went to the libraries and I had a great
time studying the literature because it
was easy to read because it turned out
to my amazement that the question of
mortality and even aging is it was then
a complete backwater really relative to
most of the other things that you think
about and you can and a metric of that
is the following I started looking at
these big fat biology textbooks that
they use in undergraduate biology
classes that cover all of biology and
you know they were very useful by the
way my own education just obviously
learning things that I had not been
educated about but I'd look in those and
I quickly discovered I must read a least
half a dozen maybe more and I discovered
sure there's a chapter of metabolism a
chapter on growth there's a chapter on
reproduction on genes on even ecology
and so on nothing on mortality or aging
you could look in
index you most of them wouldn't even
mention it and I thought this is
extraordinary you know when you think
about it it's the second most important
event in the in you know in an
organism's life its birth and death
differ and there's nothing about death
and I was absolutely shocked at that and
then I discovered as I say reading that
and it was fairly easy to read the
literature because there was not much
technical stuff having been done it was
stuff that you know you only had to know
sort of freshman biology to be able to
follow it and there was nothing
quantitative almost nothing I mean there
were survival curves and so on but I
mean I invited biologist Bonnie Bassler
to give a colloquium in the Caltech
physics department and she talked about
bacteria and quorum sensing and the
students were blown away because you
know they were pounding the our graduate
students in physics were pounding their
heads against these problems that they
really needed to work hard just to ask a
question that's right that we didn't
know the answer to and in biology like
you don't know the answer to half a
dozen questions that you think up over
the afternoon right sure exactly so it
was quite different so anyway I started
in the evening so to speak or when I was
you know stuck on my physics I was doing
which was very easy to be stuck off
because I was still doing string theory
or being slightly depressed about the
SSC I would work on this problem I'd
think about it I'd read as I read a lot
of the literature and I started thinking
about it and that got me and one of the
things I quickly discovered in the
literature were these remarkable scaling
laws and because in looking at the
literature for longevity I learned that
there was an approximate scaling law for
longevity as a function of size the
function of the mass of an organism and
it was a relatively simple one even
though there was a lot of variation in
the data
[ __ ] noise in the data but how should we
think about what a scaling law is yes so
let's talk about that it's because I
wanna that's a good point of departure
so a scaling law I mean in its most
simple form is you know you take any
system and you ask what happens if I
increase all of its lengths by a certain
parameter double its size triple its
size what happens so the simplest
obviously is if you take a rectangle and
you double the size of each side the
area doesn't double it goes up by a
factor of two times two four so it's
very driven of the volume of a similar
object goes up by a factor of eight two
times two times two
since the simplest form of scaling
scaling law it's a one case of square
and the other case of cube so so
generalizing that one can then ask about
that's just go to immediately to biology
if I measure some characteristic of an
organism and it could be something as
fundamental which is what I want to get
into has metabolic rate how much energy
how much food if you like does it need
each day to stay alive how did the 2003
calories roughly speaking that we need
how does that scale from the smallest
mammal the system in mammals form the
smallest mammal to the blue whale how
does it you know is there is there some
regularity so that was the thing that I
also learned about that these scaling
laws and in particular the scaling of
metabolic rate had already been
discovered people had collected they
well a man named Max climb originally
had collected this in the 30s and
discovered an extraordinary regularity
that it was incredibly simple scaling
law which we call a power law which was
said in English and then I'll say well
translated so the scaling law is as a
function of mass he goes to the 3/4
power of its mass which means what is
what goes as the 3 I'm sorry the
metabolic rate
how much your heart rate well the
measure would know just just how much
food you need each day let's stay with
that firstly that that scales with the
3/4 power of mass that's the way you
said mathematically 3/4 power of mass
means the you cube the mass that's the 3
and the quarter means you take the
square root twice so it's a very bizarre
law from that viewpoint well at least
it's saying that bigger things need more
food yes
but less per gram less per gram and
systematically so that so the thing that
surprised me was that it was so simple
mathematically simple and also that
there was a law anyway that any law
should exist because we have this notion
that natural selection invokes the idea
of random processes within an
environment so and that any
characteristic of an organism whatever
it is that including the organism itself
but also it's the nature of its cells
the nature of its genes have a unique
historical history I mean they they're
historically contingent it depends on
what's happened in the past and an in
she ologist love to show us the
diversity absolutely so that's that big
that's Darwin that's their big thing and
that's why they often argue physics and
mathematics has actually nothing to do
with biology because there aren't any
simple things like that and here was a
law about maybe the most fundamental
quantity of biology how much food you
need to stay alive and it was showing
extreme regularity and whereas as I say
from a naive natural selection viewpoint
you would have expected if you trooper
plotted on a graph metabolic rate on the
vertical axis versus size on the
horizontal axis the points would be sort
of all over the graph reflecting the
historical contingency
of an evolutionary history of each
organism yeah why shouldn't two mammals
of the same body mass have very
different metabolisms because they had
different mechanisms that evolution
exactly so this was pretty amazing to me
but what was even more amazing was that
if you looked at any physiological
characteristic that could be measured or
any life history event such as how long
you live how long you take to mature the
rate at which you grow but all these
kinds of things they also had a very
similar very simple regular behavior and
in as I say just emphasized again in
marked contrast to the naivete that we
have about natural selection furthermore
and this was critical from a physicists
viewpoint the the what because the
exponent the three quarters in metabolic
rate was repeated across all of these
different characteristics so totally
different quantity for different
quantities flying questions some was
mundane if you like his heart rate some
as you know profound really as lifespan
we talked about earlier but you know
things like you know the length of the
your aorta something like that you know
or the number of leaves on a tree as a
function but so I learned and I was very
fortunate at the time that a few years
earlier four books had come out a pretty
much the same time summarizing all of
this so there's must be anywhere from
fifty to a hundred of such scaling laws
depending on what you want to call them
and it had been before the Second World
War it had been an area because they
were discovered in the 30s it was an
area of significant concern so many
famous biologists had spent time
thinking about it Huxley and Darcy
Thompson
and JBS Haldane and so all the some of
the big names in in mid-century biology
and but with the with the late 40s and
50s came the molecular revolution and
the discovery of DNA and the double
helix and that completely changed
everything and these these questions
which are to do with multicellular
they're not just to do with
multicellular organisms but to do with
sort of more macroscopic behavior as
everyday life scale was sort of swept
under the rug and forgotten and
everything returned everything turned to
molecules at genes in particular genes
so that that was the paradigm we should
be thinking about biology and in
retrospect it sort of parallels a little
bit physics that you know I ate my years
as a high energy physicist I think that
part of that culture was that look all
we need to know is the fundamental laws
and that's why the theory of everything
was so important because once you got
the fundamental laws we can calculate
every anything and everything including
biology you know all it is in some weird
way is turning the crank for these
equations and that will pop all these
marvelous and I don't think it very many
people said that explicitly nor did
would they even have defended you know
you asked but there was some sort of
this attitude exactly that underlay what
was important versus what was sort of a
waste of exactly so I don't think
anybody ever said it and you're exactly
right if anyone had said that people
would have said well yes of course we're
it's very public you know those
fundamental laws are crucially important
and they will lead to all this but it's
true you will need to develop other
techniques you know it would have been
there would have been a very soft
version yeah but it was still there and
it was in the culture
and also in the culture was in a certain
sense again I did actually hear it
stated but it was not very common was
all the rest of those things those
things were engineering engineering yes
that was Georgia Georgia and it was very
much echoed you know goes back a long
way of course to the famous statement of
Lord Rutherford you know the discoverer
of the atom you know the famous one all
science can be divided into two physics
the stab collected yes I was always
slightly embarrassed by them and then
one of my Caltech colleagues has a
poster with that quote on his wall so
this was part of it you so we know it's
there and but anyway so going back to
the molecular revolution and the
genomics what did had evolved was a
similar kind of arrogance I think has
evolved that that is everything so that
we ended up you know not so long ago
with this idea that you know it was
fantastic we should map the human genome
which is phenomenal and it's a fantastic
achievement but the hype about it was
once we done that and so solved
everything
engineering after that you know but had
personalized medicine and all diseases
and all syndromes are gonna be
understood and solved and so on I mean
we're at the Santa Fe Institute and one
of my first visits to the Santa Fe
Institute was by Leroy hood was one of
the initiators of the genome project and
he was here talking about it and I
listened to it was a very very good talk
but he said this very explicitly and I
was amazed that he was giving that talk
because he wanted to get computer
scientists and people think my company
involved in doing the engineering part
anyway and I thought at the time my god
this is really extreme but we had that
so
so this area had migrated this area to
do with organisms in particular and the
more macroscopic thinking had migrated
into ecology right so ecology and
evolutionary and what's called
evolutionary biology that became the
home for some of this stuff and I got
involved because I had started working
on this as I said on my own and as I
thought about I decide learnt about and
discover I discovered by reading I
learned about all these marvelous
scaling laws and I said this is
unbelievable I can't believe that there
isn't a theory out there that the
biologist said that it's all been solved
and this is now you know hold on I
discovered there wasn't any it had just
stopped literally stopped in its tracks
so I thought this is a marvelous problem
to work on now in the context of is does
physics have any relevance from biology
and we have a theory that would help
explain this exactly Amin and it has a
curve an you fit the data yes can we
derive can we construct a principled
theory from which these laws can be
derived and we can also make further
predictions and just so we the people in
the audience have the direction which
these things go you've mentioned that
larger animals live life at a slower
pace yes so let me elaborate because I
just said the scaling laws so let me
give you some other examples so heart
rates for example decrease with size but
they decrease in a very regular fashion
so that it is that you I set him in the
metabolic rate is you take the you qubit
and then you take the square root twice
for heart rates they decrease according
to taking the square root twice that's
it the minus one-fourth the minus
one-fourth it's in mathematical language
and
and so it is with many other things I
mean the the the the radius of your
aorta scales with one that is the 3/8 is
the analog to the 1/4 but you see the
eighth has a four in there you don't get
5/7 you don't exactly so this number for
permeated all of these scaling laws so
this is fantastic for physicists there's
a true universality and and and
physicists concerned that's what
physicists concern themselves about you
know the deepest level are their
systemic kinds of phenomena and do they
have kind of what we call universal
behavior and are the universal
characteristics and here was one saying
something astonishing that this
unbelievable unbelievably complex and
diverse phenomenon called life around us
is constrained by the number 4 yeah I
mean I thought this is like magic where
in the hell does this number come from
so that was the state of mind I was in
when I started thinking about it and I
did and and the first thing you think
about is what is common I mean you
realize that whatever the underlying
mechanism is it must transcend the
evolved design because it's true for
plants trees is true for mammals is true
for birds insects and so forth in other
words there's some happy place for an
organism to live and evolution gets you
there take different paths many exactly
exactly can take many different pause
and it gets manifested in different ways
in the sense that you know we have a
beating heart and a respiratory system a
tree doesn't in fact we are bunch of
tubes you know we're like plumbing but a
tree is a bunch of fiber bundles joined
together and sprays out like electrical
cables sprays out so you know these are
quite different engineered designs but
they satisfy the same scanning law
you know so you ask yourself something
has to transcend that and then you know
it doesn't take very long to think it
through and realize that look the the
the huge problem that an organism has is
that it's kept of an enormous number of
components particularly cells it's got
something we have we have ten ten
trillion ten to the fourteenth and they
have to be sustained and serviced in a
roughly speaking democratic and
efficient fashion and it's obvious what
what has happened we've developed
networks these modern if you if you
think in that those terms you realize
you are a bunch of networks everything
from yours I said circuitry respiratory
systems your renal system even your
bones are a big network a nervous system
your nervous system your neuro system
the very thing that you think of as you
the white and gray matter in your brain
those are also just branching systems
the synapses and neurons and axons are
all networks so in sorry a network of
course is not a particular TV station or
so I could draw a piece some dots on a
whiteboard or a piece of paper and
connect them with lines that would be
you're thinking of a particular kind of
hierarchy yes most of these networks
that you it's not it's not absolute but
most of these networks are hierarchical
like your circulatory system there's a
beating heart as an aorta and that comes
down out and then it branches and
continues to branch all the way down to
serving your organs all the way down to
the capillaries the feed cell so it's
this branching network and you know most
of the dominant networks in our bodies
have that kind of characteristic so I
sort of had this idea that it must be
some Universal features of networks
there must be well in the language of
physics is a universality class of
networks that have this feature that
have some
we're in them this one quarter this fall
they know about the number they know
somehow what could that be so what could
that be
indeed so what I did first was simply
try to solve the question of how does
our circular system work just to take
that as a physics problem simple one my
problem good a warm-up it turned out to
be quite complicated and it was a
wonderful child
mathematical physics challenge which I
was quite frustrating at times but I
enjoyed immensely I could use all of the
classical mathematical methods that I'd
been taught as a graduate student and I
used throughout my career and they all
came to bear on this and I eventually
solved it and but I then in solving it I
had to think what is the principle what
are the principles that are constraining
this Network and I'm sorry just by
solving it you mean constructing a
mathematical model that match the match
I'm sorry the matched yes what we know
about business means by solving it
that's what I'm sorry yes so I had
mathematical equations so you've tried
the mathematical equations for the blood
flow through your vessels and that's
complicated because it's a pulsatile
flow it's being beaten by the Hazem
boom-boom-boom-boom and not only that it
goes through a vessel and then that
vessel branches so some goes down one to
one down the other and so you've got to
deal with that and then it bifurcates
again or trifer kate's even so you know
had to deal with all that and so I did
all that mathematics and there's all
kinds of formula you derive for that but
you have to constrain it it's not some
arbitrary Network and that's what I
realized quite early on and it turned
out I put together three generic
principles but only in the context of
circular systems to begin with and then
I realized later
these were generalizable to
all these networks and they were the
following the first is the network has
to be what we call space-filling has to
go everywhere every cell in the body has
to be supplied by blood has to be
supplied by oxygen oxygen so so
therefore the terminal unit the
capillary has to end near the cell so it
can be fed so let's called space-filling
and we know how many cells there are
they fill the trunk sure ii was which
was something to do with natural
selection as i thought about the scaling
laws and our relationship to other
animals are the mammals and that is that
yes we look quite different but we
obviously have a lot in common but in
particular as different mammals evolved
natural selection kept certain things
invariant it had certain building blocks
it did not reinvent cells in order to
make a dog has distinct from an elephant
it kept those same building blocks so in
terms of the network the cells were
essentially the same but also with
things like capillaries the end of the
network you don't you know that's the
thing that feeds itself so I natural
selection is naturally very lazy right
it takes what you already so loses how
can I improve things a little bit so you
don't reinvent things a pro I every time
and you're very parsimonious in that so
that was the second idea the kind of
invariance of terminal units and the
last was taking a row for this viewpoint
and that is that something is being
optimized you know physics operates
almost entirely dead and almost all that
was particularly of a fundamental level
from optimization principles and you
know we that's our fundamental equations
of motion are derive a ball from
optimizing action the beam of light goes
from one point to another it takes this
the choice is hard so this is
fundamental to physics
and so I postulated hypothesized that
the our circuit system in particular has
evolved so as to minimize the amount of
energy our hearts have to do to pump
blood through it you know that is and I
didn't have a quite formulated at that
time but I'll jump ahead it was only
later when I started you know a very
intense collaboration with biologists
and natural selection is what they think
about all the time and it was really
this idea that the real reason for that
from a natural selection viewpoint is
that you minimize the amount of energy
that is needed for the organism to stay
a la have to live so that you can
maximize the amount of energy you devote
to reproduction and to raising of
offspring so until your Darwinian
Fitness you want to maximize you
maximize Darwinian Fitness by minimizing
the amount of energy that you need to
[Music]
support and sustain the system so this
was one very specific case going back
now to the circulatory system that you
minimize the amount of energy our hearts
have to do to pump blood through it and
so we have all these equations so that
you have three principles three
principles you have the you know the
dynamics and then it's a matter of
solving equation now those equations
with those constraints and it it's very
similar to what we do and you know what
we were doing in field theory in high
energy physics it's quite it's the same
conceptual framework that is anyway out
of that popped to my absolute delight
and amazement this one quarter power now
I have to interrupt that make it it
sounds very straightforward but it
wasn't I struggled a great deal first of
all trying to solve them and understand
the biology and so on
and a serendipitous serendipitous event
occurred and that was that I got a call
from the vice president of the Santa Fe
Institute who said who called me up to
say Jeff there are less biologists very
well-known biologists that is involved
with the Santa Fe Institute and he is
very interested in getting a physicist
involved in trying to understand scaling
laws of biology and I said I got any one
I said I can't believe this I said I
can't believe I've actually the last
almost year you know as a kind of hobby
I've been working on that and I think
I've close to solving it but I need
about it's fantastic I need a body he
may need a visitor's ID the biologist so
that it's got a very long story short
that began an extraordinary
collaboration with a man named Jim Brown
who had moved recently to the University
of New Mexico and was involved with the
Santa Fe Institute and we and he had a
marvelous student named Brian engquist
who was himself now well-known ecologist
and a fantastic collaboration developed
where we got all this straight and it
took us almost a year from then to get
everything straight and it was a huge
commitment by the way because I was
running hind you physics at Los Alamos
right study at the day job I still had a
day job I was running the I was involved
with a theory group and we were running
we were still involved with many high
energy experiments so and I was the
spokesperson or the connection with the
do we anyway and Jim ran a big ecology
lab went out in the field and so on and
we both agreed to devote Fridays to this
at the Santa Fe said it was huge it was
an enormous commitment that came after a
few meetings
and we did and it was it and they
required that actually so we would meet
we would meet here at the Institute you
know between nine and ten on a Friday
morning and they would leave here about
2:00 or 3:00 in the afternoon and we
would the three of us begin we just be
at the blackboard a lot of it was
blackboard and a lot of it was just
[ __ ] you know going back and forth
because I didn't know the biology and
how should I put it they were
mathematically challenged so I had to
take you know really things that we take
so much for granted and really work hard
at explaining them and they were
fantastic at explaining in very simple
terms biological mechanisms and and and
also very importantly what is important
because that in one's education that is
something that is something we don't
often recognize is having a mentor who
really guides you it's not actually
teaching you now but what is important
and this is the way you should be
thinking about this and to those out
there who are not professional
scientists we should point out that this
idea of standing at the blackboard and
discussing things and learning things
and having the feeling you're making
real progress it doesn't get better than
that
no absolutely thank you sure my god
honestly it was fantastic it better that
in a very curious way your ideas are
going back and forth in your writing
equations and then you realize they're
completely wrong the idea is wrong you
were complete and they get to prayer so
many times in the prayer so you sit
there you know and certainly with this I
would sit down I think why am i involved
with these guys they can't think you
know they not able to write an equation
that I'm you know and I'm sure they felt
the same way about me so there's all of
that but that's part of it and I I've
often said I know that it's not sort of
like a marriage a good marriage yeah cuz
that that all comes with it you know and
so it was a phenomenal period for me and
that collaboration lasted for Omer about
15 years
and it of course it evolved we got you
probably all postdocs and other people
joined us and other senior people joined
us you know we had a chemist and join us
another ecologist we had students from
physics students from biology
it was marvelous actually and we you
know created this body of work right but
now I don't want to switch topics too
abruptly but it wasn't too long before
you went from explaining all the scaling
laws and biology to saying well once I
had my networks oh actually I'm sorry we
didn't say where the four came from did
we
no so I get in there yes so it is from
the networks but to put it in you know
sort of simple layman's now you have to
do all the calculations and you have to
do all but but in it is roughly what the
four turns out to be is three the three
of the four is a reflection of the fact
that we live in three dimensional space
the space filling that I talked about if
we were six dimensional if we lived in
six dimensions it would be that that
would that three would have been six and
then there's a plus one and that so four
is actually three plus one and the plus
y knew that very very loosely speaking
comes from the following those
principles and in particular the
optimization lead to these networks
being fractal like self-similar you know
I mean that is they repeat themselves
one you know as one goes down through
the network bird's-eye view looks very
similar to learned in exactly or if you
cut you know if you cut a big branch of
a tree and you take it away it looks
like a little tree yeah
and that self so-called self similarity
you can derive and that is is fed by the
optimization this optimization kind of a
constraint leads to that and it turns
out one of the curious properties of
fractal geometry is it increases what we
think of the dimensionality of the
system and
you can increase it and and it increases
it maximally and that maximality happens
to be one you can't go more than one and
so biological organism natural selection
has taken advantage of fractal geometry
to increase the dimensionality and
increase its efficiency and its way of
interfacing with whether whatever the
external environment is so otherwise
large mammals would need enormous
Lemoore caloric input absolutely to get
through the day but these networks solve
the problem of with maximum efficiency
getting the of it on the abscess exactly
exactly so we are all manifestations of
that so and there's networks all over
the place
there's networks all over the place and
indeed somewhere along the line it
started to occur to me that you know
this is a paradigm for other problems
and in particular social organizations
and in even more particular cities it is
a you know and and of course there's
been a long history of thinking of
cities as kind of super organisms and we
often use metaphors from biology
metabolism of city DNA of accompanying
and so on and so I was I started at
least thinking about it and I thought
well but again a certain difference
event came along okay and that is I was
here at the Santa Fe Institute I mean I
was not part of the Santa Fe Institute
but I was here on this once a week basis
and I gave a colloquium one time on my
biology work and in the audience were a
couple of very good social scientists
who said who came to me afterwards and
said you know we're so intrigued by this
I'm sure this we can that we can use
this to start understanding things about
cities and other social organization
site and to cut a very long story short
we formed a new collaboration giving us
the impression that all great science
happens by accident because you just
well mine does in a way mine does and I
did
I feel relaxed it happens
accident I don't know if it's accidents
but I often think that any new idea that
I've had I often feel has come is not to
do with I know this sounds weird but
it's not much to do with me
but I don't think it does sound weird
because one of your discoveries about
cities is that they sort of provide the
environment for these things to have
sent by letting the interaction why
exactly so and I think that is what is
happening to all of us you know and it's
sort of sort of the unconscious part of
the city yeah and it is so I often say
the you know I even said and others I
think have probably said it in many ways
the city is our greatest invention
because it's a machine that brings us
together in and and facilitates and
enhances social interaction and provides
positive feedback mechanisms for
enhancing that to create ideas to
innovate and to create wealth and you
know I mean it's certainly true that
most of those ideas that most of those
conversations and interactions that take
place don't lead anywhere or they're to
do with personal life you know I mean
they're not but amazingly that
phenomenon occasionally leads to the
theory of relativity or to Google or to
you know Microsoft or to the said of it
whatever but that's what the city is it
is that machine for doing that a friend
of mine a theoretical physicist was you
know we're having a late-night
conversation and he says the following
he said if you divide human history into
the most recent ten thousand years and
all the ten all the years before that
there were a lot more people in
prehistory right a lot more people older
longer than ten thousand years ago but
all the good ideas seem to be in the
recent 10,000 years and we were
wondering why that was and there are
hypotheses like well they were too busy
hunting gathering and
in fact the data are that
hunter-gatherers a lot of lots of times
yeah so in fact those like the city
density know the city is the mechanism
by which we do this so anyway we formed
a collaboration and unlike the bio
unlike the biology where I was extremely
fortunate that the scaling laws had
already been put together develop you
know the phenomenology so to speak had
been organized in these four books that
I mentioned earlier that had been
published and by the way I didn't say
because these people who were quite
senior people had worked on it earlier
this was the end of their careers
molecular evolution genetics had taken
over and they were kind of summarizing
they and the amazing thing about those
versus when I discovered that there was
no theory they just showed all this
stuff anyway
the cities weren't not in that position
what I learned was that surprisingly no
one had looked at the scaling of cities
so you want to know about how things
like presumably energy use or roads or
something like that change as the city
gets bigger exactly so you could ask you
know I think the very first question we
asked when this was still an incipient
collaboration it was where the man
that's now sort of social physicists
signs of what record on these days works
and social organizations came out of
physics and in duck hell being at the
ETH in Zurich and a student but we
worked together first was how does the
number of gas stations scale with city
size very mundane kinda question but one
would guess the number of people's
proportional to the number of gas yes I
guess so
when we looked at the data we discovered
amazingly that it looked just like
biology it was that it scaled in a very
systematic way following this same
mathematical power loss scaling but the
exponent the analog to the 3/4 the
quarter powers I mentioned earlier that
was not a quarter power it was point
eight five meaning to put it in English
that every if you doubled the size of a
city instead of meeting twice as many
gas stations very roughly speaking you
only need 85 percent so there's this
marvelous economy of scale the bigger
the city and the original paper only
looked at for European countries and
they all expressed the same scaling law
and somewhat later when the
collaboration was was more formed more
formalized and in particular two people
brought on board one was physicist very
very good physicist named Louis
Betancourt who had been working came out
again came out of nuclear physics
actually and a man named Jose Lobo who
was had been associated with the Santa
Fe Institute was an urban economist he
was I think Cornell at the time but they
were very good data analysts and they
one of the things they did was they
looked at data from around the globe
just first gas stations and discovers
the same scaling law everywhere but even
more amazing was that if you looked at
any infrastructure at least the ones we
could get data for like length of all
the roads I think for electrical lines
water lines blah blah blah they all had
the same scaling with this 15% this
point 85 and that was sort of amazing
and it was just like biology except
point eight five sort of point seven
five kind of thing is that because
cities are not truly three-dimensional
space filling well we wondered about yes
and in fact I think that yes from that
viewpoint the answer is yes
dimensionality plays a crucial role and
ultimately does but I should say right
up front now I would say ah so let me
back off a second so the obvious thing
is again even though you know New York
doesn't is not does it look like Los
Angeles which doesn't look like Chicago
which doesn't look like Santa Fe they're
all network systems and they were doing
the same thing yeah so just as the Whale
doesn't look much like an elephant which
doesn't look much like a human being
they're actually doing all the same
things biologically and so in that sense
not surprising they're scale versions of
each other so it is that cities and
within a given urban system ha indeed
scale versions one another but following
in terms of infrastructure a similar
laws as biology but with a exponent of
0.85 as you say to do somewhat with
their dimensionality they're more
two-dimensional obviously but also their
network systems that was the other point
I mean it's clear is that the like
biology they're networks that road
networks electrical networks
what are they optimizing some equivalent
that's the question what are they
optimizing and how much are they
optimized so in terms of those networks
I believe that in many ways those
networks are optimizing things like time
to get from A to B and distances you
want to supply things as directly as
possible but you've still got to do it
in a network way because you got a
supply you know it's but is it safe to
say we don't yet have the development of
theories not a tease them so we don't so
one of the thing if we we can make if we
make certain generic assumptions that
are quite analogous to the ones in
biology but also ones to do with
something that I haven't mentioned yet
which distinguishes social systems and
particular cities from biology and that
is social networks now this is the most
important thing and is to do with what
we talked about before that cities are
there to enhance social networking
and it is the structure of social
networks that are being reflected in the
socio-economic quantities and if you
measure socio-economic quantities we
find something we don't see in biology
and that is a reflection of this
positive feedback loop that occurs in
social interactions and that is that
your social network is calling the
bigger we are the bigger the way the
bigger we are the more we have per
capita rather than the bigger they are
we are the less per capita which
dominates biology so our heart rate
slows down as we have more man rights
but I just love the fact that as we move
into the city the pace of life is pace
of life naturally walk faster exactly so
everything goes backwards in biology
yeah the instead of as I said the bigger
you are the less per capita the bigger
are the more per capita the higher the
wages per capita were mostly the rent so
and the rent obviously all these things
there the high the amount of
construction per capita goes up the
number of patents produced per capita
the the the innovation of a city
increases the amount of crime increases
per capita the amount the number of AIDS
cases increases per capita all following
the same systemic scaling law of an
increased by about 15% with every
doubling so it follows again the same
mathematical power loss scaling the
exponent now is now bigger than one its
1.15 that's the 15% and that's called
super linear is it possible that the
physical proximity afforded by cities
will someday be replaced by networks
that are virtual that are online well
that's a very interesting question I I
don't think replaced so my I used when I
first did this work I thought exactly
along those lines and then I thought you
know we've already had that because the
invention of the telephone
already did that it already made
something
virtual even though we know their lines
going it's we've gone one step further
than that of course but you know what it
did was that it contracted time I mean
up until that point you could only have
an interaction in with with no time
right delay if you were face to face
otherwise you had to wait hours days and
in some case months and suddenly you
could have the equivalent to face to
face right there in your home and that
had a profound influence so I think
bigger than the the the IT revolution
they which has taken it truly virtual
because it's out there in cyberspace and
so forth but and and and so I would say
that the IT revolution has done what the
telephone and by the way things like the
steam engine did because by the way the
railroad did something sort of like the
telephone a contracted space throughout
the world Shrunk the world because until
the railroad most people didn't move
more than 10 to 20 miles from their home
in their entire life didn't I read from
you that no matter what the
transportation system is people have an
average commute time of an hour by mouth
yes that's a standard number that the
Georgian hour each way yes it's been
expanded to an hour you know now but yes
so the size of a city it's been
suggested there's the traditional size
of a city typically this is this is very
hand waving is given by the how far you
can move in that actually now one hour
by whatever the transport is so it just
expanded with the transportation and now
you're not shy about having policy
recommendations on the basis of this
point of view right I mean we were
making choices about how to live how to
govern ourselves what to do for our
infrastructure what we learn from these
well
have been no I have actually been quite
I interact quite a lot with the you know
policymakers and the urban geography is
an urban economists but I'm I'm very
loath to make explicit policy decisions
or recommendations other than the
following this I'm passionate about the
urban urban planning in particular has a
very checkered history here it is it is
operated urban planning both in terms of
building new developments in enlarging
cities mitigating problems building new
cities roughly speaking is worked by
rule of thumb this is what we've done in
the past this is what we do it's very
truly phenomenological not what would
make a theoretic narcissist no so it
work you know this way we did it and
I've learned that not just from reading
the literature but I've given talks at
big conferences and people have come up
to me and said listen I run a company
and we're building a small town of
15,000 people and I had no idea any of
this existed and we just you know the
way we bit well you know we should have
a park here I mean I've exaggerating a
little bit but a little bit you know but
that's what it is and it's very much
rules of thumb and it is no accident
that all the since almost all synthetic
cities have been failures Brasilia
Canberra even Washington DC it's taken a
long time for Washington DC to become a
real city and so in Islamabad they've
all been essential disasters and we're
seeing it repeated tragically I think in
China because China has this pressure to
build several hundred new cities in the
next 25 years and you know they're just
building them willy
just buildings and soulless and it's
gonna have horrible repercussions and it
is already actually
well I'm very sad because we are running
out of time but let's circle back to
where we started because you mentioned
this question of I don't know whether
it's a responsibility or at least the
question of how scientists relate to the
usefulness of what they'll do very good
some of us myself included have rarely
done a piece of science directly
improves the life of anyone but me and
my friends and other fans of theoretical
physics and cosmology other scientists
of course have changed the world in
dramatic ways how should we think about
this yes so I of course like you I most
of my career as I said was in
high-energy physics and I'd never done a
practical thing in my life however and
and I had a faith and it is a faith that
you know understanding more and more
deeply eventually has profound
implications not just for you know
because of for its own sake but actually
propagates through and in some way we
don't fully understand but in some
diffusive way actually influences the
world we live in and so let me give you
an example that influenced me
tremendously in very a might but I was a
graduate student so when I was a
graduate student I was I'm at I'm a
terrible experimentalist I was terrible
I almost failed every time in both as an
undergraduate and graduate student
getting a degree because I couldn't do
the bloody experiments but I always felt
one thing I did feel was that physics
was sort of at some level of
experimental science because that's its
power that you can not only observe but
you can test and and you know there's an
iterative scientific methodology and so
I thought you know be good to go into a
lab and really see how it all works and
at that time I was a graduate student at
Stanford and my name Arthur shallow had
joined the faculty he been at Bell Labs
and was the co-inventor of the laser
price for it a little bit later and he
was just setting up a lab and I was his
third graduate student and I joined him
and I told him exactly what I just said
but I'd like to do it and see and I said
maybe I'll stay him be with anyway I was
a terrible expose listen by the way it
was a terrible theorist and so it was
very good because I was sort of the
house theorist and I would explain you
know papers the theory papers to hitmen
so really nice symbiotic relationship
but one day at night in the lab we had a
dart had in his lab because we had this
biggest laser in the world actually and
and I was talking to him about being a
scientist and I want to be a scientist
and I said but I'm gonna do hind you
physics they're so useless and that's
Dean armor
and you've done you know you were Bell
Labs at least and and I said like this
now you're doing work that is obviously
useless I said you know I mean you know
this is God I do with anything obvious
lasers it's marvelous it's marvelous
atomic physics you're you're
resurrecting atomic physics from the
ashes and it's marvelous but it's not
got nothing to do with anything
and he said Geoffrey you're completely
wrong he said look he said this is gonna
revolutionize the world because he said
you know we always show where my
visitors through the land we take this
big block of wood and we fire the laser
we drill a hole through it do you
realize that we're gonna have lasers
powerful enough the way better drill
holes through steel not only that will
bear to cut steel to extraordinary
accuracy and this is gonna revolutionize
the entire planet he was completely
wrong it did not revolutionize the
planet it did revolutionize a teeny bit
of Industry fact of course and it's
allowed laser surgery but it did not he
was wrong but he was also right that it
did something the laser revolutionised
in a serendipitous totally unpredictable
way and that is the nature of course of
basic research we have no idea you know
who in the hell knows he could
hi well I don't even speculate but it
does so that influenced me tremendously
I mean I'd like to think that this
influence propagates forward but I do
worry that I did not have a motivation
for thinking that but met then the
second event and that was much later so
I was at a postdoc at Cornell and I got
to know a man named Robert Wilson who
was an extraordinary man and he became
director of Femi lab which was that
period not the biggest accelerator
before we had the LHC and so on and he
had to go through some rough times in
Congress being attacked for exactly this
question and there is a famous occasion
when he was being strongly attacked
about you know the role of this kind of
research and the question came from a
senator saying you know mr. Wilson this
is all wonderful stuff it's marvelous to
know these laws but what does it got to
do with anything for example I said what
has he got to do with the defense of
this country you know it's coming from
the Department of Energy where we make
bombs and so on what what the hell does
learning about these elementary
particles and the symmetries and all the
things you've told us about got to do
with the defense of the country and Bob
Wilson said senator I have absolutely no
idea how this will help the defense of
the United States but it will make the
United States worth defending
and there was spontaneous and that is
you know that's the spirit in which we
do this I think that's right I think as
you know as well as anyone else average
human being has 3 billion heartbeats
right and it's about what we're gonna do
with them you know it's fun to try to
extend our lives but also we're living
our lives and discovering new things
about the universe it's one of the best
ways that's what's being a human being
is and I think that is the highest level
to which we should all attain actually
we should all try to aspire to in some
way or another and you know science has
that characteristic
working on problems that seem to be have
no practical if perceived influence on
the world around us is you know is one
of the things that should be supported
and one of the sad things that has
happened in the intervening years is
more and more the funding agencies are
focusing on you know what have you done
for me lately and how is this gonna help
immediately
your little podcast can do a tiny bit
well I hope so because I mean it's
ironic that I've ended up working on
things that could be perceived as being
very practical it's my answer and I hope
have us again but with a physicist
big-picture worldview of thinking about
these systems well Geoffrey Wes thank
you so much for Thank You Sean for
having me thanks for the conversation
[Music]
you
[Music]